folks Peter Brown here at Comic Con 2014
in Nintendo's gaming lounge I with
Daniel product marketing manager at
Nintendo things are crazy they have a
lot of people here today how are things
going going well so far it's been a lot
of people around here people were
waiting in line before you even open at
ten this morning it's probably be this
way though it's been this way the whole
day and are probably stay this way all
through the entire comic con awesome one
game we got right here is a legend zelda
hyrule warriors alright hyrule warriors
here and something a little different
from e3 that we're doing differently is
that we're actually people play with
midna for the first time we did show
bhinda off at e3 but now you can play
with minda you can see right here
because this wonderful person here
playing using midnight and be able to
jump around and what's really great
about hyrule warriors essentially it's a
celebration of legend of zelda because
it's a game inspired its dynasty
warriors inspired with zelda combined to
create a game where you really have a
chance to use the legend of zelda
characters in a way you've never had
before because using a regular game
you're just playing his link but now
you're between a play is empa midna
zelda we just announced a druid we
announced criticism princess ruda is
also in there as his chic a huge amount
of character to play and it really gives
that sense of empowerment where you get
to actually take control neck take down
huge amounts of armies that are invading
the hyrule so you talk about these huge
amounts of armies that's sort of like
the core of dynasty warriors for people
who may be familiar with zelda but not
dynasty warriors what is the sort of the
flow of the game play that people can
expect when they when they get this game
for dynasty warrior you are nothing with
a dynasty warrior series we're here in
high rewards basically what you're doing
is fighting massive numbers of enemies
and being at the ability to kind of use
your attacks to take out large amounts
at the same time and also long that
you'll be fighting against officers who
are be like or like caps essentially who
are more powerful enemies if they go
through and then eventually even get to
boss fights as well but the way the game
progresses from normally when you're
going through it there's a map on the
upper right corner and there's causing
this fight between the two army to see
who's taking sides and you're gonna be
given objectives live as you're going
through it like you need to go defend
this keep you need to go attack this
area and you're basically helping
influence the overall battle what's
going on in the game and that's the
basic we were doing cover the entire
time is going to these different
objectives as you go through the game so
obviously the characters that you're
controlling are from Legend of Zelda
games right but I assume the bosses are
as well I know I fought one yesterday is
that the case throughout other
original bosses the people can look
forward to are they all sort of homage
is to the past most the game is a much
of the past there is a character that we
have enough that is a brand-new
brand-new for that part of Legend of
Zelda series at all named Lana he's a
white sorceress she has a book she's in
this game that's a new character that
wasn't part of it so there are some new
characters being thrown into the mix
you'll have to look forward to seeing
what other characters come out or where
their bosses might come into the game as
well that are not Legend of Zelda but
the majority of the game is inspired by
The Legend of Zelda mainly from twilight
princess ocarina of time and Skyward
Sword so what's the story like in this
game because I think we've got a good
understanding of you know the setting
the character is the flow of the
gameplay but what is the actual
storyline that's sort of driving
everyone to fight essentially some dark
forces come over and brought an invading
army against the hyrulean against Hyrule
so then link and others are now trying
to lead the hyrulean army against this
evil force that have come to attack
Hyrule that space tell the story you
shared so far this point in time you
have to discover who these dark forces
are and what's really going on okay so
what sort of areas are going to protect
I know right now we're looking outside
of hyrule castle Oh as you know what
what do we have right here so this is
this is minda pulling out a thing
exactly like Linkwood in the past right
so this is just one of those touches
that you get even has the chime we're
all used to hearing when you open it
tries like doo doo doo doo like that
whole like that chime you hear when you
open a chest that's in the game and you
can find different things like that like
the bomb there's also the hook shot he's
been shown in the game or you might find
other weapons to be able to unlock as
well as you progress through okay and so
like I guess I was wondering you know
you have hyrule castle yesterday i
played a little bit of the i guess it
was the mines the Goron mines in caves
where you were piled in katy elegant
kaiser you're playing through so far
i'll be showing some different levels
and again there are inspired from
different areas we've should we've shown
parts of sky law from Skyward stories
been shown other parts but another we've
just we've shown as well throughout
different builds of the game so far this
is the man we've been showing so far
which is right outside the hyrule castle
awesome so this game is coming out in
the fall I assume number 26 actually
some enroll soon that it's coming up
really quick yeah awesome alright well
Danny think of your time as always stay
tuned to gamespot for more Comic Con
2014 content
you